my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here fine all right whatever whatever
wow whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
that's why we'll see
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's the guy gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter miles you have a
baby
I'll take it from here miles
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
ah send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing everyone
keeps telling me how my story is
supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spider-Man
[Music]
and then I looked at my oh cool ah let
me guess he died
foreign